on va montrer on va visiter ce musée
ensemble peut-être cela donne-t-il des
idées à ceux qui aiment les cartes
ce musée que vous désignez donc comme
l'inde et le plus prestigieux même des
musées du monde dans ce domaine on va
visiter avec gérard dalmaz et michel
levasseur
on va voir que la france c'est vrai a
joué un rôle très important dans
l'histoire des cartes reportage noble
compagnie ou tripous de manants la
planète tapent le carton depuis
l'invention du papier les instruments du
diable 10 est au confessionnal ruines
tellement les seniors que louis xiv
interdit le célèbre jeu du pharaon
ce n'est pas pour rien que le trèfle
symbolise l'argent musée français de la
carte à jouer à dame de coeur une des
créations françaises montent à l'étagé
pour nous exposer les cartes d'ici et
d'ailleurs
cette milieu de l'an 2000 occasionne
siècle quand par exemple les lyonnais
crée déjà nos quatre couleurs en italie
la renaissance pour jouer la bonne
société commandait aux artistes des
petits tableaux champetier voici
l'ancêtre du tarot chariot le triangle
fille c'est donc la représentation d'un
chardat triomphe on aperçoit une belle
dame entouré de quatre servante dans la
partie supérieure lequel charrette tirée
par deux cavaliers deux jeunes paj donc
sur des chevaux il s'agit d'une carte
enluminés rares évidemment commandé par
la cour des visconti sforza de milan
mais vraisemblablement réalisée par un
artiste fait rare m
1793 révolutionne les cartes nouvelle
donne
les têtes tombent les emblèmes aussi la
famille royale passe le sceptre aux
valeurs titre régénérer vérité liberté
justice vertu bravons nature le monarque
devient le grand père le valais égalité
et coiffée du bonnet phrygien ou d'un
béret franco français et ne cherchez pas
robespierre seul rousseau figure grâce à
son atout le contrat social mais
français aujourd'hui connaissent ce jeu
là c'est à dire des figures à double
tête avec un index en coin et surtout
des figures nommé on connaît tous
alexandre argine judith hector alors
avancé cartes à double tête
il faut remonter à l' empire et soul
empire napoléon faux premier décidant
d'un seul jeu officiel pour tous les
français voilà ce qu'on trouve ce sont
des cartes entier quant aux cartes
coquine du 19e pudibonds les personnages
habillés ne le sont pas toujours
normal puisqu'il joue sur la
transparence